BRIAN: WE ARE IN NEW YORK, LET’S
GO TO JERUSALEM WITH THE PRIME
MINISTER OF ISRAEL, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
STEVE: FIRST QUESTION.
AFTER A 5-YEAR INVESTIGATION THE
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL COURT
LOOKING INTO WHETHER ISRAEL,
PARTICULARLY ISRAELI SOLDIERS,
COMMITTED WAR CRIMES THE
TARGETED CIVILIANS, WE’VE SEEN
THE HEADLINES, TELL US WHAT YOU
CAN ABOUT THIS STORY.
>> I THINK THIS IS AN OUTRAGEOUS
DECISION BY UP POLITICIZED
KANGAROO COURT THAT GOES AGAINST
THE ONE DEMOCRACY IN THE MIDDLE
EAST, ISRAEL, WHOSE SOLDIERS
HONORABLY AND SCRUPULOUSLY DO
EVERYTHING TO AVOID CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES WHILE FIGHTING THE
WORST TERRORIST HONOR TO A DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO COMMIT
CASUALTIES.
THEY PUT ON THE INVESTIGATION,
ISRAEL.
THEY DON’T PUT ON SYRIA WERE THE
ASSAD REGIME HAS BUTCHERED HALF
1 MILLION PEOPLE OR IRAN EVERY
MONDAY AND WEDNESDAY COMMITTED
WAR CRIMES.
THIS IS PURE ANTI-SEMITISM.
THIS IS A PERVERSION OF JUSTICE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
TO US TODAY BUT TOMORROW IT WILL
HAPPEN TO YOU.
YOUR SOLDIERS, THEY ARE THINKING
OF INVESTIGATING YOUR SOLDIERS.
THIS IS AN AFFRONT TO ALL
DEMOCRACIES AND EVERYONE SHOULD
STAND TOGETHER.
I LIVE IN JERUSALEM WHICH HAS
BEEN OUR CAPITAL SINCE THE TIME
OF KING DAVID.
THEY SAY IF WE BUILD A HOUSE IN
JERUSALEM THAT IS A WAR CRIME.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
ANYTHING YOU BUILD BEYOND THE 67
LINE IS A WAR CRIME.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
PARTICULARLY OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE
THE ICC, THE INTERNATIONAL
COURT, WAS BUILT TO PREVENT THE
TYPE OF HORRORS COMMITTED ON THE
JEWISH PEOPLE BY THE NAZIS AND
THEY ARE TURNING THEIR GUNS ON
THE ONE AND ONLY STATE OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO STAND FOR AND I WILL FIGHT
FOR IT, FIGHT FOR THE TRUTH,
FIGHT AGAINST THIS PERVERSION OF
JUSTICE UNTIL THE TERRIFIC
DECISION IS AN OLD.
WE STAND UP AGAINST IT.
AINSLEY: THE NUMBERS ARE
AMAZING, 88% OF ANYONE OVER THE
AGE OF 50 HAS BEEN VACCINATED,
SOME 75% OF THOSE AGED 50 YEARS
OLD ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A GREEN
PASS.
WHAT IS HIS ADVICE FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD?
HOW DO WE DO WHAT YOU ARE DOING?
>> 90% OF ISRAELIS ARE JABBED AT
LEAST ONCE, MANY OF THEM TWICE
AND THE OTHERS -- HOW CAN I SAY
THIS?
WE ARE RUSHING TOWARDS HERD
IMMUNITY.
HOW DO WE DO THIS?
QUICK DECISIONS, TREMENDOUS
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM,
MOBILIZATION OF THE CITIZENRY,
THEIR HEALTH AND LIVES ARE
DEPENDING ON IT.
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THIS.
IS REAL USED TO BE KNOWN AND IS
KNOWN AS A STARTUP NATION.
FROM TODAY, IT WILL BE THE
VACCINATION NATION.
WE ARE SHARING EXPERIENCES, THE
PRIME MINISTER OF DENMARK AND
AUSTRIA COMING HERE TODAY IN 20
MINUTES TO BEGIN A MEETING TO
SHARE AND BENEFIT OTHER NATIONS
AS THEY COME OUT OF COVID-19.
STEVE: YOU GIVE THE OPTION TO
STAND OUTSIDE THE VACCINATION
CENTER.
SHOULD THEY HAVE THE CATEGORY
PULLED UP?
HERE IN NEW YORK THEY WERE
THROWING THEM OUT.
I WISH WE TOOK YOUR LEAD FIRST
ON THAT.
IS THAT A SMALL POINT OR A BIG
POINT?
>> IN ISRAEL, PEOPLE ARE WAITING
FOR A VACCINE, WE OPENED UP
EVERYTHING AND GET VACCINATED.
WE STARTED WITH THE OTHER ONE
BUT THE FIRST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD TO EMERGE FROM CORONA WITH
THE GREEN PASSPORTS, YOU CAN GO
TO RESTAURANTS, THEATERS, MOVIES
AND SPORTS EVENTS.
I DON’T THINK WE ARE COMING OUT
COMPLETELY WE WILL HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK FOR SOME TIME.
WE ARE LOOKING INTO THE FUTURE.
LET ISRAEL TO PRODUCE THE
VACCINES OF TOMORROW.
VACCINATION NATION IS WHERE WE
ARE GOING.
BRIAN: SINCE ISRAEL IS ON THE
LEADING EDGE AND I KNOW YOU’RE
RELUCTANT TO GIVE ADVICE BUT
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY ABOUT WHAT
THE UNITED STATES IS DOING AND
HOW TO FIX IT, DIFFERENT STATES
HAVE DIFFERENT METRICS AND ARE
DOING DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING, TWO
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS AS FAST AS
YOU CAN.
IT SHOULD BE DONE BY EVERYONE.
YOU CAN GET OVER COVID-19, WE
ARE GETTING OVER COVID-19.
AINSLEY: HOW DID YOU DISTRIBUTE
THE SHOTS?
OTHER BIG-BOX STORES HELP BUT
HERE IN NEW YORK YOU HAVE TO GO
TO A CONVENTION CENTER AND HAVE
TO SIGN UP ONLINE AND ASKING THE
ELDERLY POPULATION TO WAIT 5
HOURS TO GET THERE SHOTS AND YOU
CAN’T ASK SOMEONE TO DO THAT WHO
IS 95 YEARS OLD.
>> HAVING A LOT OF MULTIPLE
PLACES BUT WE IN ISRAEL HAVE A
UNIQUE SYSTEM OF HMOs, DIGITAL
DATABASES, EVERYBODY WINS IN.
USE OTHER ELEMENTS, CUT THE
BUREAUCRACY.
BRIAN: YOU WENT TO SCHOOL HERE
FOR A WHILE, YOU’RE FAMILIAR
WITH SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE.
THERE IS OUTREACH IN THE
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMUNITY IN
MANY POCKETS FOR THIS WEEKEND
UPDATE JOKE, THERE WERE PROTESTS
OUTSIDE THE TAPING THIS WEEK,
HOW IS REAL WAS ONLY A PORTION
OF THE POPULATION.
>> THEY VACCINATED HALF OF THEIR
POPULATION AND I GUESS IT IS THE
JEWISH HALF.
>> THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I BROUGHT VACCINES ESPECIALLY TO
THE ARAB COMMUNITIES, ARAB
CITIZENS AND VACCINATED AS MANY
AS WE CAN.
MUST’VE GONE THROUGH HALF A
DOZEN ARAB COMMUNITIES, TALKED
TO THE MAYORS, BROUGHT THE
LEADERS AND THE DOCTORS, THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
THE INTERESTING THING IS NOT
ACCIDENTALLY, MANY MANY CITIZENS
ARE VOTING FOR ME BECAUSE NOT
ONLY I BROUGHT VACCINES FOR
EVERYONE, BUT BROUGHT PEACE FOR
EVERYONE.
I BROUGHT FOUR HISTORIC PIECES
THAT WERE HELPED BY DONALD
TRUMP’S PEACE DEAL.
IN A FEW WEEKS, EVERYBODY IN
ISRAEL SAID WHO BROUGHT THIS?
AND WE ARE WITH YOU.
I AM THE FATHER OF MY OLDEST
BOY, WHEN I GO TO OUR VILLAGES,
THEY SAY FATHER OF THE YEAR, WE
LOVE YOU.
WE ARE CHANGING HISTORY ON THAT
TOO.
STEVE: A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH HOW YOU REOPENED
YOUR COUNTRY AFTER THE LOCKDOWN
YOU ACHIEVED FOR A WILD.
A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
REFUSING TO OPEN TO IN PERSON
LEARNING.
WHAT DID YOU DO IN ISRAEL THAT
WAS EFFECTIVE AND SAFE FOR
EVERYBODY, IN NEW JERSEY THERE
IS A CLASS-ACTION LAWSUIT, THEY
ARE FALLING BEHIND.
>> WE OPENED KINDERGARTEN, IN
MOST AREAS WE DID THAT AND NOW
WE ARE ADDING THE ADDITIONAL
GRADE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE ARE
GOING TO DO IS ADD ANOTHER MONTH
IN THE SUMMER TO HELP CLOSE THE
GAPS BECAUSE THE -- IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT, INTELLECTUAL AND
EMOTIONAL EXPERIENCE OF BEING
WITH OTHER KIDS AND TEACHERS.
ZOOM IS GOOD BUT NOT THAT GOOD.
IN CLASS LEARNING TURNS OUT TO
BE SO VALUABLE AND ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN YOUNGER AGES.
WE ARE BUILDING IT UP IN THE
SUMMER.
AINSLEY: WHAT IS YOUR
RELATIONSHIP LIKE WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN?
HE HAS BEEN IN OFFICE FOR 44
DAYS.
>> I HAVE KNOWN JOE BIDEN ON FOR
44 DAYS THE CLOSE TO 40 YEARS
WHEN I CAME INTO THE EMBASSY IN
1982.
AGO SENATOR FROM DELAWARE, A
WARM RELATIONSHIP OVER THE
YEARS, JOE BIDEN IS A FRIEND OF
ISRAEL, I KNOW HE IS, HE IS
COMMITTED TO HIS REAL BUT I ALSO
KNOW SOMETIMES WITH THE BEST OF
FRIENDS AND FAMILIES WOULD SAY
WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING, THE
JOE BIDEN UNDERSTANDS, MY
COMMITMENT TO PREVENT IRAN FROM
GETTING A NUCLEAR WEAPON IS
ABSOLUTE AND I BELIEVE HE
UNDERSTANDS AND RESPECTS THAT AS
THE PRIME MINISTER OF THE ONE
AND ONLY JEWISH STATE, WIPE US
OUT FROM THE FACE OF THE EARTH
OR THE MAP OF HISTORY.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO PREVENT IRAN FROM GETTING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND SO FAR WE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
BRIAN: I HOPE YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
AND HOPEFULLY THE
ADMINISTRATION, THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME, BEST OF LUCK IN YOUR